i think that a lot of people now are
just behaviorally compulsive when it
comes to spending time on their phone if
you've ever done this this is part of
the compulsion right you're on a plane
you pull your phone out of your pocket
you know that you don't have signal and
yet you still cycle through a bunch of
the different apps that you would do
usually you know that there's no payoff
coming that's not part of the addiction
that's part of the compulsion
what's happening people welcome back to
the show it is a 450 000 subscriber q a
episode i know it's not been long since
the 400 000 episode but it's been a good
run this year okay and after 500 it's
going to be every 100 000 subs that we
do q and a's so this is the last little
one we're going to do as usual ask for
questions on instagram and youtube and
locals and twitter
and it took assistant ben an entire day
to put them into a document so if yours
doesn't get answered today i am sorry
tried to condense them down so that lots
of questions about rogan or andrew tate
or whatever have been pushed into
individual ones uh and if yours doesn't
get answered then next time 500 isn't
too far away let's get into it
noob gato marking what a username
thoughts on nofap
i don't know man like no flap to me
seems like it makes sense for people
that are pathological fappers if you've
got your hand on your penis
for many hours a day or you're scrolling
through pornhub a lot then simply by
stopping doing that you're going to free
up perhaps two hours maybe more and
that's going to give you a lot of
productivity benefits however
i don't think that the levitating off
the ground and women being able to smell
your pheromones and testosterone through
the roof
i'm a little bit more cautious around
that so i i don't have a particular
aversion to nofap but i'm also not a
fanboy
johnny cucci
he sent an article to chris kavanagh
about audience capture and other
phenomena do you feel that any of these
are applicable to yourself or are there
any that you guard against
yes i think that any creator chris and
myself included would agree that
audience capture is a big deal that you
need to be careful of the people that
don't understand
when you are a creator and you start
making stuff on the internet you find
that certain pieces of content end up
resonating more with the audience and
that can create a feedback mechanism
where you stop creating what you want to
create and instead create what the
audience wants to see so this is like
the sold out grifter shill like red meat
for the whatever mob
thing that people get accused of and the
problem is that once you start to go
down that path it's basically impossible
to turn back around
i think that it's
permanently
a dynamic that i need to be conscious of
and i try as best as i can it's
difficult because people can resonate
with an episode because it's genuinely
amazing and interesting and adds value
or they can resonate with an episode
because it's red meat click bait
lowest common denominator limbic hijack
[ __ ]
working out which one's which is is kind
of difficult however
being friends with someone like chris
and a bunch of other people helps to
keep me in check because they're not
going to take my excuse about why i did
x y or zed
and just you have a felt sense you have
an understanding like look am i doing
this because i genuinely care about what
this person has to say and i think that
they're interesting and i'm curious
about them or is it because i know that
it's going to get clicks and i don't
care about them or it's against my
morals like playing that balance is
what's important
alexander rosenfeld what do you invest
in crypto real estate stocks or
something else so almost all of my spare
net worth is in real estate i've got a
bunch of properties in the uk
massive fan of buy to let's and that's
been something i learned from the
business partners i had when i was in
club promo
that was their process for building up
cash and then putting it into something
which hedges against inflation which
actively earns which can be capital
gains over time
but i'm not
i'm not super optimized when it comes to
the way that my money is moved around
real estate to me is something that's
good but
my stocks and stuff i've put some money
into the s p crypto i've got maybe five
grand i had five grand in there which is
probably like one grand now um but yeah
real estate for me is where i like to
put my money i understand it it's safe
as far as i can see uh and yeah the fact
that you have a
capital gains generating asset that
actually creates revenue in the interim
as well is pretty cool
[ __ ] me tads
tact vicky
what was it like being on jre after
looking up to him for so long and having
listened to so many episodes of his i
found the episode fantastic by the way
so congratulations and well done thank
you uh it was a little bit surreal being
on it but nowhere near as surreal as i
thought it probably would have been
um the whole experience was dope he we
mean him have been texting a good bit
since
i got off and
i look forward to seeing what happens in
the future with him like
he's a dope guy he is an unbelievably
competent uh podcaster as well like you
think is someone that knows what they're
doing you think like i've done 500
episodes of this i've got myself to a
position where i genuinely understand
the art form and then you step into the
arena with somebody like him and you go
oh holy [ __ ] there's levels to this his
ability to be
very casual and meandering with the
conversation whilst still keeping it
moving his use of silence is fantastic
his ability to ask questions and push
when he needs to to sit back he's able
to prompt responses with statements
rather than questions which is
unbelievably cool uh the guy's boss and
i'm happy that i'm connected with him
i'm happy that we're texting and i'm
really really happy that he was super
enthusiastic about meeting me and
hearing
lessons and stuff that i've created
it's pretty cool it's been a good few
weeks
lewis lex friedman is already booked i
hope so me and likes are buddies but uh
he is also
trying to create a robot army or
whatever it is that he does so
podcasting isn't the number one priority
that he's got and given that i guess
we'll just have to wait and see
that being said the rest of this year
has some
i've got three bookings that are
just outrageous for the remainder of
2022.
what can i say about them
i can say that one will be in austin
one will be in new york and one will be
in las vegas
those are the three that we've got
um they're not
dates and timed in yet so i can't quite
release it but
they're
beyond huge and the one in the final one
uh in vegas is just
insane so yeah hold on for that one and
lex hopefully at some point
communist cat
is it correct that you're in the austin
tx area yes it is
i remember that there was a get-together
some time ago it would be cool to do
that on somewhat of a regular basis
maybe once a quarter or every month or
two or maybe virtual in a zoom type
called this is from the locals community
modernwisdom.locals.com
yes we did do a meet-up and it was very
very fun and i did it with rob henderson
my good friend and we just had a blast
and maybe between 1500 people turned up
it was a lot of people a hell of a lot
of people and everyone was super
interesting and super smart
i would be well up for doing that again
so yeah keep your eyes peeled i guess if
you're in the austin area also back in
the uk in september for a couple of
weddings and a couple of other
recordings that i've got
so i might try and do something in the
uk but it's probably going to be too
tight so uk might have to be next year
claire mcleod what resources did you use
or training did you undertake to develop
your speaking and conversation skills
for your show so i think i might have
mentioned this before but a big part of
it was simply just putting the reps in
with the show itself so you know 500 and
whatever it is 10 20 episodes within the
space of four years like do anything 500
times
and you you're probably going to get
pretty good at it uh
i also started working with a speech
therapist a guy called miles usher if
you google speak well i think is his
company might be speakworld.org or speak
well.code uk
um he's fantastic i have had some
uh comedy coaching i've had a bunch of
comedy coaching actually and i'm
considering going to start doing some
improv stuff as well you have to
remember that people like rogan right
they've greased the groove and sharpened
their tools of communication and
presence
and yes and
style communication they've done all of
that on stage
thousands of times
before they even started doing
podcasting the difference is if you
haven't got that stage type background
where you've had classical training or
professional training or whatever the
only way that you can do that with
podcasting is to practice in public
and that means that all of your errors
are there for people to observe and
scrutinize and laugh at over time but
one of the beautiful things is that it
means it's tracked that progression you
know you can see episode 150 100 150 200
250. you can see how that skill set
develops over time which is cool because
you don't you know moving from one movie
to the next it's not sufficiently
frequent to be able to see the
iterations
um but yeah those are the main things
and it's also been very intentional
about it as well like i've genuinely
tried to become better at speaking and
conversation and getting comfortable
with silence and all of that stuff
cirrus is your accent considered to be
jordy do you think it will become more
texan now that you live in austin
um
i would say that it's a twang of
northern people that really really know
the
uh northeast of england as accents go
will detect a bit of t side in there uh
rather than geordie
i don't think that most people would
people in the uk would probably detect
that was from somewhere up north but
they wouldn't really be able to say
where uh i definitely don't think that
it's going to become more texan i have
started picking up some text and slack
it's more american slang just because it
was words i would have to say twice so i
can't say um drop me off just outside of
those bins there because there's bins
outside of the house i live in austin
that trash cans right or like outside of
those like outside of the trash
uh i was talking about
um
dollars using dollars instead instead of
talking about pounds like just little
things it's terminology that i've had to
change
but uh in terms of accent i i can't see
me picking that up
silent seeker to become the current
podcast king you need to fight either
joe rogan or mike tyson in a no rules
bout who would you choose and why
do you have any martial arts training or
would you be eyes closed windmilling in
um
[ __ ] that's a good question so i watched
joe have his knee
he had a bump on his knee like a um
bruise the first thing that happened
when i arrived at the studio was he came
in shook my hand said hi and then his
nurse that's on site at all times
poked a hole in his knee and i watched
him squeeze like
bruised fluid
out of his knee
for 10 minutes
i really don't want to be anywhere near
an angry version of that guy uh i think
mike didn't mike tyson say that he was
on the verge of death recently there was
headlines talking about how mike tyson
was adam and he was nearly going to die
i still think mike tyson's going to be
an angry angry guy but if i can somehow
incapacitate the arms i reckon i've got
him at the legs so i'm going to take
mike
and strategy just just run at him very
very fast hope that he gets tired he
smokes a lot of weed try and catch him
on a sunday or something when he's
blazed out of his mind i i don't know
ahead of the zeitgeist do you think
you've been disadvantaged by your looks
that's a good question
i
was uh
lamenting the difficulty of somebody
that comes from a modeling or reality tv
background for being taken seriously in
the world of
whatever you want to call this like
sense making or
talking on the internet right that
it can cause people to have um
presumptions about what it is that
you're going to talk about or about the
quality of your insights
because you have a particular look or
whatever i've kind of come to realize
that
it's that's just a difficult
like needle to thread to be able to say
yeah like the fact that you come from
modelling background actually makes
everything more difficult like maybe it
does but it's very difficult to say that
a
person who came from an ugly background
would not be more disadvantaged than
someone that came in like just because
many professors might not have super
cool drip doesn't mean doesn't mean that
they've got a better advantage than
people that come from other backgrounds
so no i i think overall no the halo
effect is real you know people that are
whatever like classically good-looking
or something have better outcomes
throughout their lives
it's supposedly
and
i don't know stuff seems to go well for
a lot of my friends that are good
looking so maybe that's it maybe it's
maybe all of the intellectual virtue
integrity building wisdom
stuff is horseshit and maybe everyone's
just being judged on their looks for the
rest of time
madeleine kylie what are the main
insights you've gained from joe rogan
experience
um what so many like i reflected a lot
about this uh in the week after i
recorded with joe a lot of this stuff to
do with his ability and i've tried to
bring
the elements of that that i think i'm
lacking
across into the show so i'm trying to be
more casual more conversational in terms
of actual insights from the conversation
the main one that i took away which i
put in the three minute monday
newsletter and if you're not subscribed
you can go and sign up right now it's
chris will x dot com slash books free
reading list with 100 books that you
should read before you die and it signs
you up to my mailing list and a lot of
the things that i spoke about on rogan
i've written in that newsletter over the
last two years they've been concepts
that i've come up with or stolen from
elsewhere or pieced together and the one
that i came up with there is just
because something is difficult to attain
doesn't mean that it's valuable so rogan
was talking about the fact that
a lot of people would hold up in high
acclaim the watch that you're wearing or
the car that you're driving or the girl
that you're with and people get confused
and believe that that is something which
is worthwhile
simply because it's difficult to attain
but then you attain it and you realize
hang in a second this isn't actually
worthwhile it's just hard and the um
challenge of getting it is used as a
proxy for the value of it
and i was like holy [ __ ] i got there
before he finished saying it and i was
like this is amazing so that was the
best insight that was like three and a
half hours sat down with him that one
insight was worth it 100.
b couch 37 how do you retain all of the
knowledge and insights that are
introduced to you on your show
i don't
uh there's this concept from tim ferriss
called look at me using a concept from
tim to explain how concepts don't stick
in my mind
there's an idea from tim ferriss called
the good [ __ ] sticks and that is the
best solution that i've found if you're
someone that consumes a lot of content
on the internet
and you don't have the type of demeanor
that has a perfect external brain
personal knowledge management system
thing like tiago forte or ali abdal
if you don't have that just allow the
good [ __ ] the stuff that resonates with
you existentially to stick about because
it will the the insights like that one
from rogan about worthwhile and valuable
i can't not remember it like i couldn't
forget it even if i wanted to and i
think a lot of the time we see something
that
doesn't resonate with us and we presume
that
because it's interesting or cool maybe
or said by somebody that we think is
respectable or has a good insight about
life that we should remember it because
i don't know maybe we'll need it in
future and maybe that's true but for the
most part i think we consume more
information we consume too much not too
little and given that the golden rule is
about filtering not seeking so it's
about getting
signal from the noise as opposed to
getting more noise
and for me the best solution that i've
found and maybe this is a cope right
maybe it's a cop that i don't have a
structured personal knowledge management
system
but just allowing the stuff that really
resonates with me to stick about and
everything else just falls away so the
reason that the ideas that i got to talk
about specifically on rogan but also on
the show the reason that i know them so
well is because i genuinely care about
them there's not much that's in my mind
that's something that's there simply as
a story that i can bring up it's because
it was something that was super
meaningful to me and i thought [ __ ] like
i need to keep a hold of that
that's the best solution that i've found
just
allow the stuff that you care about to
rise to the top maybe do a little bit of
studying you know revisit it every so
often certainly the newsletter for me is
a hugely important way
because i have to teach it kind of i
teach it to myself i guess i'm only
writing to me there just happens to be
like 40 000 people on a mailing list
that are listening to it too
having an outlet is great you know the
feynman technique of teaching in order
to be able to remember yourself but just
allow the good [ __ ] to stick i think
that works
delia burgess how long did you grind
away at modern wisdom before you felt
like it really gained traction oh uh
so
i think we did
more plays in a single day
on
youtube
one like many of the days so far in 2022
than in the entire first
two years maybe even the first three
years of the entire channel
i certainly know that i did more plays
this week on audio
than the entire first year
or first two years of audio plays
so basically forever like that's the
um
that's the way that any exponential
curve looks right that every time that
you start to zoom out a little bit more
and move a bit further along the curve
the previous however long looks poultry
because it's just flat everything
becomes flat flat flat and then it's
just this hockey stick
so forever basically like we've me and
dean have worked in
relative silence and darkness for
three years three in a bit years
probably until the peterson episode
but peterson was like episode 360
something i think
so
we've done a hell of a lot of work up
until the point in which we're no longer
completely invisible and then even
looking at back at the plays that
peterson got back in the day whatever
april 2021
what we do now now makes that look tiny
so basically if you want to do something
like a podcast or a youtube channel
don't expect immediate results but
expect huge results if you keep on
sticking at it
five years down the line because most
people have already given up by that
point
lewis why don't you have more followers
all of the content i've seen of yours is
of highest quality with stimulating
conversation between thoughtful
individuals even after the mecca that is
joe rogan keep up the hard work cheers
gsu lewis uh i don't know man like
literally what i just said it's a very
very long game to get to
any appreciable size of growth and
especially on youtube you have to think
even though
you guys that are listening and me i
adore long-form conversations i can sit
and listen to lex go on with somebody
for four hours or rogan do a big episode
but that's not what most of the internet
is after most of the internet is
bored by tick tocks you know like
there's comments on the youtube channel
that says who's got the time to sit and
listen to an hour and a half
conversation
well obviously not you so
it's still an unbelievably
niche
um
medium
to be pushing stuff down think about
even tv hasn't caught up with this tv
needs to split up segments into two to
three minutes so that they can get to
the next ad break within the next ten
i think that
we will get there i'm confident in the
conversations the skill set that me and
dean have built up the workflow that
we've built up like everything's there
it's just a case now of continuing to
enjoy the ride
find new interesting people
get better at what i need to do
network more bring on fantastic guests
try and do new different things like the
high quality productions and bring in
people that no one's ever heard of
before
that's it it's just a case of playing
the time game the more followers will
come and it's got to the stage now where
i'm pretty confident that that's going
to happen
so i don't have anything to worry about
like
more followers are going to continue to
arrive we've passed the threshold where
i think i could even stop them from
arriving
so all i've got to do is enjoy the
journey
i think
not leo tolstoy thoughts on tick tock i
saw a couple of podcasts read their
policies even your instagram pinned
video talks about that do you think it's
manipulative and making a generation
addicted yes
absolutely i do not like tik tok i do
not use it
uh the
social media guys that look after the
short videos that i make post on it on
my behalf and i do not i don't
like going on there it is perfectly
designed to keep people on there i'll
never forget me and george mack were in
dubai
two years ago there was this girl that
george was talking to in a bar and they
got onto screen time or something and he
said oh can i can you show me how much
time you spend on your phone this girl
spent 12 hours a day on her phone and
george went and had a look and it was
eight hours a day
on tick tock
absolutely [ __ ] wild like how
on earth
anybody thinks that that is a good way
to spend your time and it it's
not just an
addiction it's a compulsion and this is
a difference that i've learned from
andrew huberman
that the addiction involves a payoff the
compulsion doesn't have a payoff on the
other side of it and i think that a lot
of people now are just behaviorally
compulsive when it comes to spending
time on their phone like how many times
if you've ever done this this is part of
the compulsion right you're on a plane
you pull your phone out of your pocket
you know that you don't have signal and
yet you still cycle through a bunch of
the different apps that you would do
usually
but you know that there's no payoff
coming that's not part of the addiction
that's part of the compulsion
so yeah i i don't like tick-tock i think
that
if the opportunity was there it's 100
and that negative just
burn it to the ground
mma wrapped up why do men have only fans
i'm going to guess that you mean why do
men pay for only fans as opposed to why
do why are there men on only fans
selling their nudes
i think it's sad lonely men that are
being commercialized by
girls that can do like and
part of you thinks well is it on the
girls to not do that these guys are
willingly paying them uh
it's like the virtual girlfriend
experience thing but it's a sad state of
affairs the fact that we've managed to
get ourselves to that that position and
for all of the talk of the patriarchy
and capitalist greed
i think it's
like 10 of only fans models make 95
percent of the income something like
that it's hugely skewed towards the top
few and you have to think that this is
basically the reverse
of a politionist society where you would
have one man with many women because
here you have one woman with many men
and a lot of these men are actually
going to feel
i don't know some sense of obligation or
connection with this woman so there's a
power dynamic that's been changed there
which is pretty interesting
eddie fresh do you consider yourself to
be part of the manosphere
i don't know what that is to be honest i
brought it up to joe he laughed um
i really don't know
it would all depend on whose definition
of that it is
if manosphere means people that are
having interesting conversations on the
internet about the roles of men and
women in modern society yes that would
be me
if it's
men being
assisted in understanding their place in
the world and how to
moderate their behavior given the new uh
stimulus and the new environment that we
have yes that would also be part of it
but like the whole
red pill black pill incel mgtow fresh
and fit pua stuff
is not
that's not my vibe like i'm not bringing
on girls to berate them and tell them
that they're hypergamous and all of that
stuff but i do want there to be an
interesting conversation about how men
can have a firmer place to stand in the
world i think that that's a valuable
conversation to have i think that it
means that women will have better men to
get into relationships with women are
the ones that are single because men are
the ones that are unable to get into
relationships like it's not good for
anybody at the moment and i do think
that women are on average doing better
than men
that doesn't mean that women need to be
brought down that means that we need to
be able to help to raise men up and i
think a lot of the manasphere is focused
on bringing women back down as opposed
to helping men to focus on just look get
as better as you can that's not to say
that men don't have problems that's not
to say that there aren't um asymmetries
in the way that the world is designed or
that
particular groups have been raised up
my point is simply that
men need to do as well as they can and
they need to be playing a positive sum
game as much as possible in
collaboration with women and that
communication across the board from men
to women is one of the reasons why i
keep on bringing on girls on the show
nina power louise perry mary harrington
i'm talking to women about men's
problems in a desperate attempt to show
that you can have conversations about
this i think that's very important
andy farrell five jordan peterson and
andrew tate need to have a conversation
thoughts
do they
what would they talk about
what would what would andrew tate and
jordan peterson talk about like
andrew is
blowing up on the internet at the moment
he recently got mainstream mediaed uh
they were trying to cancel him because
of some stuff that came out a long time
ago about big brother
that
i'm a jordan peterson fan and me and
andrew have known each other for a long
time
that conversation doesn't excite me
there's conversations that i would be
interested to see andrew have i would be
very interested to see him to talk to
logan or jake paul
uh i would be interested to see him sit
down one-on-one with hassan abby
jordan peterson doesn't excite me
mark speakman how did you feel receiving
the invite to rogan
how did you prepare the night before
okay so
he dm'd me on instagram
so i'm recording the 400k q a in here
for you guys right and i'm saying
someone asked uh what are you going on
rogan i was like look you followed me on
instagram but i don't even know if the
guy knows who i am i honestly thought
that it was an accidental follow or
something
then i finished that i go to training
and i come back and i find out that as i
was saying
i don't think joe rogan knows who i am i
received a message from joe saying hey
brother let's record a podcast on
instagram
i was like holy [ __ ] put the phone down
and
honestly looked at a wall for about
three minutes just didn't know what to
say
and then
messaged dean and i
half 12 messaged him a ton of times on
facebook messenger and i was like deeney
you up dean you up i need to speak to
you teeny one he's like yeah what's
wrong what's happened i was like send
him the screenshot uh so
it's kind of terrifying it would the the
most scary thing of the whole rogan
process was the invite because that was
the biggest change
i think in um
expectation because you go from zero to
100 on that everything else you know the
preparation the sitting down the going
into the studio the meeting jamie all
that stuff like that's just once you're
once you're on the roller coaster that's
just part of you continuing down the
tracks right like the invite was the
most terrifying part
uh how did you prepare the night before
i got a taxi back from dallas
at
midnight and i got into austin at 4 00
am two days before right so
i was trying to fly back from virginia
norfolk virginia norfolk virginia flight
cancelled
moved my flight to newport news flight
cancelled moved my
flight to richmond virginia drove for an
hour and 45 to get there all thinking if
i can just get to austin tonight and
sleep in my bed i'll get one more
night's sleep and then i can do rogue in
the next day
got there
flight from richmond gets delayed
delayed delayed delayed finally actually
managed to make it and i'm thinking for
[ __ ] sake if i wake up in richmond
tomorrow morning with rogan the day
after that i'm gonna feel i'm gonna be
worried i'm gonna be concerned i need to
sleep and feel good blah blah
got into dallas at midnight and then got
an uber for four hours from dallas
to austin which cost
320 bucks it wasn't that bad but the guy
drove a tesla so he had to stop twice on
route
and to be fair the dude that gave me a
lift was an absolute legend young kid
just did everything and anything that
was needed to get me back uh was doing
push-ups and lunges during the break so
he's obviously into personal development
and if i ever see him again i'm going to
buy him a beat because that was a big
part of it
uh woke up the next day
and then managed to
move myself into a like relatively okay
sleep cycle got to sleep that final
night and then yeah trained on the
morning felt great
went to rogan's at whatever 1pm or
something and then cracked on
her seagrow
hood 350k pod you mentioned not wanting
to go past the level of fame any change
okay yeah so there's this um article
from tim ferriss called
13 reasons not to get famous and you
should go and read it once you've
finished listening to this because it's
very very cool he basically talks about
what happens if you blast through a
ceiling of fame i actually told rogan
about this after the podcast when we
were chilling out
and um
i don't think it's a concern for me
right now
i mean i'm
not even small for i'm like so small i'm
like nano fry
um
but there definitely is a such a thing
as too much fame um
and i wouldn't like to go past it the
problem being that how do you stop you
know if the thing that you do that you
really value and care about is
continuing to grow what do you do do you
try and
be less effective at the growth of the
thing that you really care about because
maybe in two years time you're going to
be moving at such a speed that you can't
stop it when you blast through some
ceiling of fame that means that you
can't go to public gyms anymore or
whatever
it's such an interesting conversation
because so few people have this problem
so few people have the problem of
breaking through that and then for the
people that do there are basically no
mental models or accepted wisdom
around how to deal with it and also it's
like a boo it's like the um is it a
disadvantage being good looking or
whatever um
boohoo who's going to cry for the person
that's got too much status or too much
fame or too much recognition or money or
something
basically no one but it is an
interesting challenge i mean andrew tate
has definitely blasted through way too
much fame liver king too much fame you
know when you can't go anywhere without
security
to me that seems like that's a heavy
price to pay
and you need to make sure that you have
resources like monetary resources that
allow you to live a life
that is still comfortable um
and not constrained by the constraints
of fame so for instance if you don't
have
if you can't go to
the gym a local commercial gym because
you're going to be mobbed by people that
want photos or to ask you questions you
need to have had enough money come in in
order to be able to build a gym at home
and maybe have a personal trainer or
bring your friends around or do whatever
the same thing goes for dinners like you
need to be able to have a private dining
area every time that you want to go out
if that's the thing that you want to do
it's a fascinating discussion i really
want to do a podcast with somebody about
this
uh
right now not a concern but definitely
something that i keep in mind
nick rombuscus
uh favorite clothing brands i wear a lot
of zara
tons of zara that was
that's kept me going for probably a
decade now uh
that is the only place in america that
i've managed to find that is um like
consistent with the european styles a
lot of the stuff that gets made for the
american market the sizing is different
the styling is different it's kind of
big and garish
and
when it comes to sportswear at the
moment i am all over the place because
i'm in between sponsors however there
will be a new sportswear sponsor coming
on for modern wisdom very soon and i'm
gassed to start working with them
but i've got stuff from reebok they're
fantastic asos man asos crush asos own
label for pretty much everything i think
it's called
a506 or something 4506 it might be
yeah
four five or six is their sportswear
brand and they make awesome shorts and
they're 12 pounds or 13 pounds or
something and i got one of every single
different color i'm that guy
jose vargas what are your thoughts on
bitcoin and can i have half of what you
own uh jose as i said earlier on i
maybe owned five grand of bitcoin and
there is not going to be very much left
so you can have you could have all of it
and it probably wouldn't touch the sides
of your bank account
you are so very british how does that
feel
uh
imperial
mrs q how old are you i thought you were
in your late 20s but you recently said
something to make me think this is off
i'm 34
but i'll take the compliment uh
the same
week i think that i spoke about the
moisturizer thing on this
the last q a i got accused again of
having had botox which is
funny
you
ju
jung
what color is your bugatti i need tate
to buy me one apparently he's buying
everyone one so [ __ ] it
alvin rivera i heard
you were a creepy club promoter is it
true
i was a club promoter and a lot of club
promoters are creepy
i think one of the problems that you
have as a club promoter is that your
entire
um
the currency that you traffic in is
direct messages right so you're
messaging individual people saying hi
mate are you out tonight how you dialing
you out tonight i made you out tonight
like that is literally how you get
people from not being in a venue to
being in a venue
if that constitutes being a club
promoter then i was the creepiest of
them all but it also meant that we were
the most successful so
half of the course
aloo is irky
russell brand please uh
beginning to circle the outside of
russell brand's
stuff at the moment
but he's kind of gone a bit like
new world order they're coming for you
you won't believe what's happened
this is just the beginning like i don't
know i would be very interested to have
a sit down with him and go look man like
is there any way that you can ratchet
down the
volume that you're putting out online
because holy [ __ ] like it's so spicy
like everything is the most extreme
so i don't know um
he's obviously got an like a kind of an
extremist personality that's somebody
that went to the complete extreme of
drug use the complete extreme of
dedicating himself to film
did he have a sex addiction or was that
only in the film get him to the greek i
i can't remember but
interesting guy lots of things to talk
about would love to have him on the
podcast
but would also definitely need to
challenge him about
come on man like let's just [ __ ]
let's bring it down a little bit a
little bit of peace you know
uh
lj22 congratulations on 450 000.
apologies for the strange format of the
question but hopefully it makes sense
narrative one classroom b 2022 was
headlined by an 80 year old with special
guests who were 72 and 53 paul mccartney
bruce springsteen and dave grohl
respectively in the same week this took
place kate bush was number one in the uk
charts with a song that had originally
been released 37 years earlier youth
culture is suffering and these places
headlining glastonbury occupying number
one in the chart should be the preserve
of people who aren't drawing a pension
that was in quotes narrative two quote
the content that the majority of young
people will have consumed in the last 24
hours will have been created in the
preceding 24 hours hyper novelty on a
social media carousel traveling at the
speed of light content that cannot claim
legitimacy and cultural stamina as it
won't have the opportunity to endure and
be tested
end of quote in your opinion from a
societal perspective should both of
these things cause us concern or does
the existence of both simultaneously
mean that there is no issue
so
narrative one is about the fact that
older
people and older pieces of content
i like lindy's stuff
is popular at the moment
narrative two the concern is that most
of the content everybody consumes is not
lindy
um
i think that
both of these things can be true without
fixing the problem of the other
i don't have any issue with
um like older
musicians crushing it because young
musicians are definitely crushing it
like beyonce's albums just come out is
the most streamed album by a female ever
in a single day
you know lots and lots of young artists
are doing absolutely fine as far as i
can see might be wrong um
totally sweet for kate bush to be number
one in the charts with a 40 year old
song that's pretty cool
the content the majority of people have
been consumed in the last 24 hours being
created in the last 24 hours isn't fixed
by the fact that the stuff at the top of
the tree
is lindy like you can have
99 of the content that's consumed to be
not lindy and then the one percent to be
lindy i like uh proven over a long
period of time that be the stuff that's
the most visible or important or highest
status and then the 99 be almost
everything else and it'd be complete
dross just total limbic hijack [ __ ]
that both of those things aren't there's
no problem with the
uh top end stuff that is
not that is that fixes sorry there's no
uh assistance of the top end stuff that
fixes the bottom end stuff
no basically we need to try and dial
down how much content we consume
we need to encourage people to make
longer
long form or at least long life span
pieces of content that hopefully
everyone is actually going to enjoy
over time most of the stuff that
everybody creates they wouldn't even
want to see or even remember in two
months time and yet you've spent
5 seconds or 10 seconds or 15 seconds
watching it it's like that by definition
is mindless so i don't think that there
is no issue i still think that there is
an issue and no
amount of kate bush number ones is going
to fix the fact that almost everything
everyone consumes has been made in the
last day
malcolm larry how many new subs slash
downloads after jre uh don't know yet uh
right now today when i'm recording this
modern wisdom is number two in all
podcasts in america
which is [ __ ] insane
number two in all podcasts it's number
two in canada ahead of the full send
podcast then elk boys just had
elon musk on their podcast
i have no idea what to think about that
but
the youtubers already doing great uh
that's been flying pretty much all year
um like this spikes for sure but
it's just increasing the growth
trajectory it's not
it was a big bump on audio but video on
youtube is just a beast all of its own
at the moment so yeah long live the
growth trajectory
uh 51 north
did you watch love island 2022
i saw
tiny snippets on what nothing outside of
twitter i saw stuff on twitter and then
my boy collard went on
so i watched a little bit of him
um he seemed to get on great we've got a
call later this week which should be
cool to catch up with him but
no i've never watched i didn't watch my
entire season through the one that i did
whatever seven years ago i didn't watch
that back i haven't watched any of the
other seasons since then
it would have been very easy to have
just done love island reacts stuff
especially as an ex islander that would
have been a way to have i guess kick
started the channel we did uh what it's
really like on love island thing which
was the first episode that ever blew up
and we could have that would have been
audience capture right going back to
what i said at the start had i just
turned into
love island
wisdom
uh that would have been audience capture
but i have no desire to spend i lived it
right i spent a month living on love
island i don't i don't need to go back
and then voluntarily
watch more of it i've spent more time in
that villa than almost anybody anybody
that's watching it so jumping in and
then deciding to watch it again it's
like
okay cameron4987
how sexy is your modern wisdom episode
with rogan going to be
if and when we get him confirmed i asked
him on the show at the end of my episode
on his luck man like i'd love to bring
you on the show and he said yes
if and when that happens we will do
something very special we'll do
something that looks
[ __ ] spectacular for that
michael
jag
where are you shopping for wavy new
garments in america dude honestly zara
is the only place like it's the only
place i've managed to find that i can
shop in so far that and asos i'm pretty
sure that asos is a british company that
just happens to fulfill in america
mindful mitch a senegalese pirate has
both your parents captive what's your
tactic to get them back
ring tim kennedy got tim kennedy's
number
ring tim say
tim i need you to go and help me kill a
senegalese pirate and i imagine that
that's the sort of thing that tim
literally lives for
ring him
watch chaos ensue
uh
nathan mars was joe rogan subconsciously
part of the plan when moving to america
if it was subconscious wouldn't have
known about it um
there's certainly a good ecosystem
that's been built up in austin because
of him being here and malice and lex and
alex jones like he who shall not be
named
uh and
everybody else that's here drinking bros
aubrey marcus tucker max like there's a
lot of creative people that that crush
that live here
uh i don't know i mean he is the guy
that makes this industry at the moment
he's the trendsetter i suppose and
getting that exposure is
pretty perfect but i it definitely
wasn't part of a formal plan at all
owen
you at chee
when will you hire people to free up
time for yourself fantastic question
ewan erwin sorry uh i
i don't know i mean i really could do
with a general manager now that just
picks out all of the bits of grit from
the operation and is
sufficiently
familiar with the way that the creative
industry works podcasting ads all that
stuff because it is very very very
effortful
that being said and this is something
that i've been thinking about more and
more recently
like sometimes i get not mocked it's
like friendly mocking i suppose but a
lot of other podcasters that find out
a lot of other podcasters that find out
how much work i do
for the show kind of
scoff a little bit because it is a bit
dumb to still be the person that comes
up with the thumbnail design brief for
the designer which is dean the person
that titles the episodes the person that
writes the show notes the person that
records the intros from the show notes
that edits the audio that uploads the
audio all of that stuff
but that being said
one of the reasons that we've had such
good growth this year has to be
attributed to the fact that i'm pairing
paying a lot of care and attention to
the stuff that goes out like the titles
perfectly match up or at least i try and
make them perfectly match up with what
the episodes are about because i was the
one that recorded the episode
i have to be the person that knows
what's in the episode better than
anybody else because i was the one that
was there i researched it i recorded it
i've listened back to it
so
part of it is i don't know inefficient
and it would be fantastic and it will be
fantastic when i get a general manager
in who can start to open up operations a
little bit and make it more slick and at
least alleviate some of the workload
from me
but on the flip side
there's a
a desire for people to
utilize leverage and
delegation before they're actually in a
place when they should do and i think
that those are the people that aren't
necessarily getting the results that
they want because
maybe the people they've delegated to uh
you know 80 or 70 as good as they are
but what they've freed up their time to
do isn't adding as much value as if they
took over the stuff that makes the
biggest difference and the biggest
difference is who's coming on the show
how well are they researched how rested
do you feel
what's the titling and the thumbnailing
look like all of that stuff like the
stuff that makes a really big difference
so i actually quite maybe this is a cope
again as well about the fact that i just
feared delegating responsibility i don't
know um but yes
if you know someone that's an
unbelievable operator a really slick
operator with years of experience of
dealing with chaos
and understands the podcasting in
youtube world unbelievably well there
will probably be a job listing for them
coming up pretty soon
and on the flip side in the meantime
i am more than happy to continue eating
[ __ ]
because i think that that is what's
setting the show apart amongst other
things from everything else
uh
the average savage episode on jre really
resonated with me and what i've been
going through thank you thank you man
it's been i've had a lot of messages
like that especially the last hour and a
half was exactly what i wanted to get
out on that show and uh
very very glad to hear that a lot of the
stuff that we spoke about has made
people feel um less alone
p
noble three
uh when lambo
you tell me man i don't even have a car
out here in america i literally don't
have a car so um
i the lambo would just be for show
fo show it would just be
it would just be for sure for show why
can't i say it for show
whatever i wouldn't be able to drive it
and i
i don't know
lambo would be cool but
i think just
getting a driver's license and a car in
america would probably be a pretty good
idea also americans are awful at driving
they're some of the worst drivers that
i've ever seen in my life in austin so
lambo might be a bad idea like prius
maybe better or like a battering ram of
some kind
uh tommy mcnee have you now given up
promoting in america full-time so i'm
gonna do a full episode or a full video
at least like a youtube video on this
soon
the
my position within voodoo is slowly
being dialed back
and there will be
like a full exit from that i think
pretty soon
darren has everything on lock in the uk
and i'm super super proud of what we've
built there and i couldn't be happier
that i'm now able to do something that i
really love and he is now able to
make more money doing something that he
is unbelievably competent at and
the it opened up roles for some of the
young lads to come through as well and
they've taken on more responsibility
like everybody's won
from this situation but
for more full details and stuff once
we've got everything signed sealed and
delivered i'll probably do a video about
that and it'll be cool because there'll
be some interesting lessons i think
about exiting a company and
letting go of a sense of
connection like existential connection
between you and something you've created
and that's difficult but it's kind of
beautiful but it's kind of sad but it's
kind of awesome at the same time it's
interesting
uh bret
jmcc is reading list v2 coming just
bought four thousand weeks you have
mentioned a few times yes four thousand
weeks by oliver berkman it's a fantastic
book everyone should go and check that
out
if you haven't got a copy of the reading
list i've already told you about it once
chris will x.com
books you should go and get it
uh v2
maybe
maybe
toward the back end of this year i would
want to have at least 50 bucks in just
because i think if you're gonna download
something
you want it to be a big a big chunky boy
right that you can continually refer
back to
i've probably got maybe 30 that i think
would
uh be worthy of going on there there's
some that i forgot about on the first
one i guess or maybe it's up to about
40. um but yeah i will do a v2 soon um
definitely that before the life hacks i
think that the reading list makes more
sense than another lifehacks thing
because
a lot of the life hacks are kind of joke
bits and they don't add quite as much
value they're funny to listen to but i
think that the reading list is like as
far as lead magnets go and something
that's free that
takes you know a month or whatever to
put together but
is basically evergreen and adds [ __ ]
tons of value to people's lives i think
it's there's nothing better than it
hook book duck when sam harris
bro sam i'm ready for you trigonometry
boys just got him trigonometry lads went
out to la and recorded with him
and bill burr
and
uh adam carolla
after they'd been on rogan after they'd
recorded with theo von
and they had someone in new york as well
those boys are crushing at the moment um
so i
sam appears to be in the mixer and i've
gotten one degree of separation away
from him but it'll happen it'll happen
eventually like i've got complete faith
i'm no reason to rush it
uh argees pick one simulation or god
simulation
connor kendall
with so many goals i have in life i find
myself crippled at times with anxiety
advice
just pick one of them man this is the
last 30 minutes of the episode on rogan
you can be anything you want but you
can't be everything you want
pick a thing
and know that it this isn't the only
thing for the rest of your life just
pick a thing and get good at that
for
90 days or six months or a year
and then go okay where am i at do i
still want to do these other things so
if you were to say have all of your
goals which are the ones i'm most
certain about which is the one that i
think is
really really important to me
just do that one first and if you can't
do that because it sounds like you're
struggling to prioritize just pick
anything
and commit to it that's the way to begin
you have to do a thing doesn't matter
about the thing just a thing
and start moving forward from there
productivity trajectory what nutritional
supplements do you use to make to stay
mentally sharp okay um
athletic greens every single day
element first thing in the morning
um
links to all of these will be in the
show notes below there'll be discount
codes and stuff like that i work with
partners that i use because it's super
easy to talk about why i like them if i
use them every single day
elements first thing in the morning
athletic greens is every day um
qualiamind which is a product by
neurohacker collective um is the
nootropic that i use i don't use
nootropics all the time or i don't use
their product all of the time but i do
use it i've used it today any day where
i just want a little bit more and the
thing that i love about quality of mind
is that they have a caffeine free
version so i'm recording this at 10 to 6
and i took maybe four tablets
two hours ago
and i have no problem sleeping because
there is zero caffeine in them they do
the caffeine version which is like a big
kick up the ass but the fact that this
caffeine free version is dope so i think
those
and then actually no fish oils i guess
would be part of that vitamin d would be
part of that those would be from my
protein
um
i think that's it i think
what like water food dietary stuff like
that but in terms of supplements those
are them and they'll be linked in the
show notes below and they'll be discount
codes if you want to go and check out
any of the things i've mentioned
kay ben dixten
when did you first link with michael
mallis
i cold tweeted malice and he tried to
clown me
on twitter two and a bit years ago
then he thought that he was going to
come on and just totally like run rings
and make a fool out of this himbo
uh and we ended up within the space of
60 minutes we ended up becoming really
close friends and then spent the next
two years talking to each other and then
i moved out to austin and now we're
mates and we see each other every week
so that was the first experience i had
with mr malice
uh
prashanth sai
what do you not like about austin so far
the heat bro it is i mean this is like
the most awesome thing to say but it is
38 39 so 100 or 102 ish pretty much
every single day and there's been 57
days over 37 degrees or 100 degrees like
triple figures in fahrenheit
and it's pretty unbearable that being
said we're in august now i
go away for a week and then i'm back in
the uk for three weeks and by the time i
get back it'll be the end of september
and it'll be sweet again so it's not a
bad price to pay
must learn more do you feel a paternal
instinct kicking in in your mid-30s or
is fatherhood still a no-no as yet dude
i can't wait to be a dad i keep on
saying this i cannot wait to be a dad um
and the difference between father
me as a father at 34 versus me at
24 or even like 28
is worlds apart i can't wait to be a
father i just need to sort
my life out first
jade
hollinsky 1990 do you ever feel like no
one really gets you even though they're
your best friends
this i think is the
fundamental
asymmetry that we have with the people
that are around us
you get to see your existence from a
front row seat right the richness of all
of the different problems that you have
the way that you feel the unbelievable
detail that you go through stuff with
and all that you ever get to hear of
anybody else is what they tell you which
is such a lower bandwidth version of
what they feel and what they tell you
isn't everything of what they feel
because they filter some of the stuff
that they feel to what they say so you
only get to see like this tiny little
soda straw view of their world whilst
seeing yours in 1080p so of course
you're going to feel alone of course
you're going to feel like nobody gets
you because there is always this
asymmetry there that being said you can
also be around people or be in a
community that just doesn't seem to
understand you genuinely on a
fundamental level and there was elements
of that for me in the uk which is one of
the reasons why i moved i think that
what you're dealing with is incredibly
normal i don't think that that means
that it should be something you either
accept or um don't try and fix
but don't treat it like a personal curse
right this is just part of the course of
being a complex individual that has
genuine varied interests in the modern
world there are
seven point however many billion people
out there you can find people that you
will resonate with
you need to go and do the work to find
them hey danny miranda what was
unexpected about your appearance on jre
um
how comfortable i felt
i think which is
a big credit to joe and his ability to
ease people in
uh i actually tracked my heart rate i
haven't got it up i should have done it
before now i tracked my heart rate on my
whoop throughout to see if i had any
peaks to see how high it went um but i
just felt super super comfortable
uh eased into it started off straight
away um
that was the biggest surprise
uh if i [ __ ] myself on this
on round two if i go back on and and
just can't get my words out then i'll
know that i used up all of the calm
charm that i had on the first one but
that was the most unexpected thing for
sure
daniel daniel here hi daniel i love your
podcasts and always listen to them while
i go bike to the gym you've set the bar
for me of what a genuine conversation
looks like and listening to these
conversations makes me want to talk to
people in this in that sort of manner
what do you recommend people to do if
they're working on themselves but they
have a hard time making friends kind of
similar i guess or a second part to the
question that was just above
you need to think about what the sort of
people that you would want to be friends
with
are like
and where those sorts of people would
hang out and go there if you want to be
friends with people that are always
talking about crossfit you need to be in
a crossfit gym if you want to talk to
people that love comedy you need to go
to a comedy class if you want to
yoga
improv
martial arts what whatever it is that
you want to do there is a way that you
can find people that select for that
whether it be
dog grooming at some dog show somewhere
or cars it's some sort of car like a
what's it called a drive by another
drive-by what's it called
like a car rally type thing just there
are people out there that have those
interests
reddit forums are fantastic you know
joining the patreon or locals community
of whatever your favorite creator is you
need to try and select for the people
that are like the people that you are
like
they're out there but for the most part
what you're trying to do is probably
retrofit the people that are around you
to be like the stuff that you consume on
the internet or the people that you want
to be like and they're not like you've
gone out of your way to find an
unbelievably unique creator or whatever
that has some niche that you care about
why would you think that that person's
going to be around the corner or just
completely like easily accessible
they're definitely not so go out of your
way try and find somebody that you think
or go to a place that you know that
those sorts of people are going to be in
that would be my advice
pancake you've spoken a lot about how
you went through an introspective
journey of self-discovery at the end of
your 20s when introspecting how can you
be sure that you're getting a balanced
and accurate view of yourself it's
difficult to tell whether you're being
too harsh or not harsh enough on
yourself
very very good challenge so
the line between
um
giving up because you are close to
burnout or injury and giving up because
you are leaving some on the table and
being a [ __ ]
is basically impossible the only person
that can know would be you if you were
able to run that existence like five
times over write and iterate some study
when introspecting how can you be sure
you're getting a balanced and accurate
view of yourself it's simply a case of
putting some work in
going and then trying out whatever it is
that you're doing whether it be
um relating to other people dealing with
difficult situations building better
habits
did the work that you do end up actually
making the real world you better
and if it didn't then
something is wrong and you will be able
to tell you know if you've pushed too
hard or not hard enough when the results
do or don't come it's in the moment that
you usually don't know so i think um
keep on reflecting is a good way to look
at this
also consider what you're doing over
very very broad time horizons the guy
from earlier on that was saying
um he has so many different goals and he
couldn't work out which one to focus on
like over a broad enough time horizon
you can pretty much do most of the stuff
that you care about it's within the
space of five years that you can't do it
so um continue to reflect
check in on how the work that you're
doing is actually showing up in your
day-to-day life like reality how does it
make you feel
and what are the sort of results that
you're getting
and
broadening your time horizons
jay
hulsman
do you find it more difficult to relate
to the generation older than you or the
one younger i am a generation ahead of
you and find your insights helpful when
dealing with younger generations one of
the many reasons why you are my favorite
podcaster well thank you very much
i
do find it difficult actually to relate
to gen z
a little bit
um there is
the audience that listens to this
podcast like brushes the top of gen z
but
isn't super young and i think that it
kind of makes sense a lot of the
problems that we're talking about here
to do with existential crises
and uh like concerned about meaning and
you know broad social structures and the
human mind nature all that stuff
i
would not have been interested in when i
was 21 years old and if that is you then
bravo because you're ahead of where i
was
when i look on tiktok at like check-ins
to see how the content's getting on
the um
like canary in the coal mine difference
between a short video that i'll post on
my instagram
one that goes on youtube
bad form bad form not turning my
notifications off
one that goes on instagram one that goes
on youtube and one that goes on tick
tock the response the different response
between each of those is so dramatic it
is insane so people just simply will not
see
the same video they'll it'll be a
completely different response and it is
so stark that
it makes me feel you know tick-tock is
what i'm using as a proxy for gen z
i struggle to understand the motivations
of those people more than any other i
struggle to understand the motivations
of many comments on the internet and i
think
we don't know what it is that drives
people to respond in the way that they
do
but
the people that respond on tick tock
a lot of the time are like people from a
different planet as far as i can see so
yes older generations i find i mean you
know i just sat down with rogan for
three and a half hours
and the guy's
like
20 years older than me
20 years older than me absolutely sweet
maybe he's an outlier but like sitting
down with my dad fine
watching stuff on tick tock and trying
to decode what's going on with that
culturally is
nada not for me
fielding z hey chris i have a question
on my mind i've been struggling with
i've been going through a bit of a rough
patch mentally with anxiety and
depression what i find myself struggling
with the most is the desire to do
something i love and the desire to do
something lucrative to ensure financial
success any suggestions on how one can
come to try and find the proper balance
between bending to the world for profit
and staying true to oneself
first off dude the uh anxiety and the
depression stuff
is
something that a lot of people deal with
i did throughout a big chunk of my 20s
you need to look at
what you're doing physically first
and you need to make sure you're going
to bed at the same time that you're
getting enough sleep you're getting up
you need to train even if you've never
trained before like you have to find
something that you will enjoy
a yoga class a spinning class some sort
of martial arts a crossfit or a
functional fitness workout or a training
partner that can get you into the gym to
do bodybuilding
make sure that you're eating right make
sure that you've got enough water in
your in your consumption throughout the
day like if you do those things and this
still exists
then there is a
discussion to be had around the
existential difficulty of like where am
i going with my life my point being that
if you don't have that foundation you
are starting on a very very rocky place
so make sure that you've got that okay
um
the balance between basically uh selling
out and doing something that you care
about
the goal is to find something that is at
the intersection of what the world needs
what you're good at and what you can be
paid for right like that's
icky guy or whatever it is straight in
the middle
it may be that the things that you're
great at the things that you're
interested in and the things that you
can be paid for
like uh sorry the things that slightly
needs the things that you're great at
the things that you can be paid for that
they don't intersect for you there may
be three completely different circles so
perhaps you're going to have to make a
some concessions around that
i would say that
once you have made a sufficient amount
of cash you can pretty much go and do
whatever you want and again like one of
the common themes we've had today is
this broader time horizon so if i don't
know how old you are but i'm going to
guess that you're probably in your 20s
or 30s
if you broaden that time horizon out and
you decide to double down make a ton of
a ton of money and then you can ease off
the gas once you've done that or perhaps
you can do something that makes you a
ton of money and begin to build up a
side hustle which is what i did
that is
a very good way to ensure that you keep
yourself feeling existentially satisfied
whilst keeping the lights on right
because being a starving artist is only
really cool in movies
being a starving artist in the real
world is just
kind of sad and
for the most part if you get bankrupted
or whatever you're setting yourself back
so you need to make sure that you keep
the lights on first and foremost so for
me the way that i did it was i front
loaded
all of my 20s with work and with
accumulating capital so that it would
give me more leeway to be able to do
stuff that i wanted this this wasn't
done by design by the way like this just
happened to be what happened i didn't um
create this beautiful perfect plan that
being said the principle that i followed
was if i accumulate capital and if i'm
financially secure
i will be able to
do more things in future i didn't know
what those things were i didn't know how
it was going to work out or whatever but
i think that chasing
financial success and wealth and wealth
generating
assets when you're young is a good way
to go about things but you need to make
sure that the physiological stuff sorted
sleep training diet social connection
water all that stuff like that needs to
be done
uh vas vasa
congrats on the milestone chris thank
you
question
how to get into the dating scene without
signing up for a dating app based on the
videos i've seen of yours i don't want
to get into that mess okay um
yes
very similar to the person that needs
friends and doesn't know where to go
like
what are you into
what is the type of person that you
would like to date into
where would that type of person hang out
that's
it it's such a simple solution such a
simple equation and it's mark manson's
models that i learned this from
if you're into fitness guys or girls go
to places where they hang out if you're
into people that do chess or world of
warhammer or whatever it is just go
there right
you have to remember that so few people
are approaching especially if you're a
girl i don't know if you are but
guys as well so few people are actually
making the first move at the moment
there is a massive competitive advantage
available just for someone that's
prepared to say hey what are you into
that that is
you've already selected yourself out
from probably 70 of men and probably 90
of women
if you just do that
go a place where there are people like
the person that you would like to date
and be the person that makes the move
like there you go
greg dandy how did you get into club
promoting asking as someone who's
interested myself as i go to uni next
year i'm not a party animal but i think
it would be interesting to try
especially as i'm expecting to be in
great shape by then love the show mate
keep it up thank you greg and good luck
at uni and getting in
yeah dude i
anybody that goes to university that is
okay with partying and wants to have a
robust social
ecosystem around them
get into club promotion because you will
immediately have
between 100 and 400 brothers and sisters
that all
kind of know you you're part of a shared
vision you'll understand about business
you'll understand about dealing with
inner
turmoil and politics and all sorts of
stuff it will expedite the learning of a
ton of stuff that you need for your
adult life
whilst you're at uni in any case it'll
help you earn money uh it's fantastic um
greg wherever you're going if it's
anywhere in leeds newcastle
manchester
birmingham
that's it
if it's any of those then there's a job
with voodoo waiting for you
if it's anywhere else
it will not be difficult just when you
get to the freshers fair have a look
around and spot the different promo
companies
they'll want you to sign up to work for
them before you go to the events go to
the events first to make sure that
they're not um selling you on a company
that's three months old and doesn't have
a portfolio of nights that's successful
you want to work for one of the biggest
companies in town because you'll get the
best benefits you'll be one of the
coolest people
your job will be easy because people
will come to you because they'll need
your guest list
so
just do that if you're in the cities up
north that voodoo's in
speak to the guys say that i passed you
on and you'll get sorted out
and if not and you're going somewhere
else just have a look at the freshers
fair see who it is that's around or when
you start going to nights the nights
that you enjoy the most just go and say
hey who who's the promo company that
runs this ask for one of the guys the
reps will snap you up they need to get
guys like you
so yeah you won't struggle
smelly cat
yes sir well done my dude question for
you as you were building your podcast
early on how did you find the energy to
do more work for no money when hardly
anyone was watching after you just
worked your regular slash survival job
or did you have money saved from the
show slash your promotion business to
where you could just do your thing no
side job congrats on the 450k subs man i
would love to see you skyrocket to a
million in a few months thank you so
would i um
yeah this is kind of back to what we
were talking about earlier on that
if you are looking to do something
where the payoff isn't immediate and
you're relying on the dopamine hit
because you don't necessarily love the
process of doing the thing
it's
you are going to have a uphill battle
right or an upstream swim and
for me it wasn't
it never felt like i was swimming
upstream i enjoyed having conversations
i got to speak to james clear was like
episode 30 robert greene i think was
episode
in the 30s as well so i was speaking to
people
dave castro director of the crossfit
games
episode three of four dan bailey episode
five so i was picking up people that i'd
wanted to speak to for a long time and i
enjoyed it
this again like it's such trite wisdom
to say you know just find something that
you love and you'll never work a day in
your life that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
at an all hands meeting no at an
internal apple meeting someone asked tim
cook about whether or not the things
that you love should actually be
difficult and tim said at apple i've
learned that the things that you love in
life you will not find easy but you will
work harder at them than ever before the
difference is that the tools will feel
light in your hands
and that's the kind of obsession that i
think is causing people to have
fantastic outcomes because not only do
they get the dopamine kicks of external
rewards and accolades and growth and you
know money or whatever but it's coming
from a place of something that they
genuinely would do in any case like if
you can find the thing that you would do
for free and to everybody else looks
like an absolute grind that is the point
of highest leverage because there in
order for them to outwork you it is
basically going to be impossible you're
going to continue to have fun while that
person has fallen asleep and banged
their head against the door because
they're sick of doing the work like that
is your point of highest contribution
[Music]
cop
how was meeting and interviewing joker
willing inspired you in your life
you were sat opposite the modern day
version of marcus aurelius and sun tzu i
would love to know how that has impacted
you your channel is the friend i never
knew i would have in this life
love your work you're doing great
what a beautiful message thank you
um
the biggest difference i think and i
just i hadn't got this before
i asked him the question of do people
overcomplicate motivation
was the difference between discipline
and motivation i'm aware that this is
his thing but it just hadn't landed
until i had a
big navy seal
saying it
five feet away from me that
discipline eats motivation for breakfast
and a lot of the time now when i wake up
on a morning if i getting up is still
my uh achilles heel getting up on time
and
when i don't want to wake up or i can
convince myself that i'm tired or
whatever it pops into the back of my
head that discipline is doing the thing
that you said that you would do long
after the state that you set it in has
passed discipline eats motivation for
breakfast are you disciplined or are you
just motivated because if you're only
motivated you're only going to do this
thing when you feel like doing it
i'm disciplined i'm getting up and i'm
going to go and do this thing
that's the biggest difference and you
know sitting and hearing that from like
the discipline guy
uh just drove it home so yeah my
discipline has been the biggest change
i'm significantly more disciplined with
stuff now don't get me wrong i could
still
observe my inefficiencies from a front
row seat every day but for the most part
it's
it's better
totos customs
question i'm 20 and life is pretty great
i'm terrified of me looking back at life
in 50 to 60 years and find that my life
was [ __ ] for a lack of a better word i
have this constant feeling of not having
lived yet and i'm scared i never will i
just developed this sort of fomo six
months ago guess a bit like quarter life
crisis i used to be super confident
basically unstoppable and now i am
questioning every decision every action
and constantly wondering what i'm doing
with my life but since my life is pretty
nice as it is if my subconscious i don't
know what it what is is telling me
i'm not in this rut and i just can't get
out of it any insight would be greatly
appreciated a million very soon
okay
it's a big one so
yes okay so because your life is pretty
nice
you are
not feeling like
there is anything wrong perhaps and
because there's nothing wrong it's
difficult to bounce yourself out of the
bottom of it the overthinking is
something that's going to cause you
um rumination shame probably a little
bit of guilt like there is ostensibly
nothing wrong with my life therefore
what the [ __ ] am i complaining about why
should i have a problem
with when there is nothing actually
going wrong
dude this is unfortunately i think the
um
it is a byproduct of being someone that
wants a lot in life right that
you are
striving for more you're someone that
can see the potential
uh brilliance that you've got in life
and true hell is when the person that
you are meets the person that you could
have been
that is not something that you want to
have happen uh
that being said bro you're 20
like you need to give yourself a little
bit of a breather like if you're
thinking about these sorts of questions
at 20 you are light years ahead of where
i was it took me until
27 28 to even begin to glimpse the
corner of these sorts of questions i had
my head at my ass for almost all of my
20s
so try and relieve a little bit of
pressure off yourself right there are so
many things that you can experience and
enjoy in life and if you are vacillating
and turning yourself inside out with
this
ambient sense that there is something
wrong
all the time all of the [ __ ] that you're
supposed to enjoy when you're young is
going to be
tarnished
because you're never going to actually
feel present while it's happening
and that is not something that you
should be
you should be enduring right you're
young there are things that you can do
when you're young that you can't do when
you're older you can spend from 50 until
70 considering the higher meaning that
you can add to the world and yes do you
need to set yourself on a trajectory
early on for sure
do you need to obsess over it when
you're 20 probably not so i would say
try and find things that get you out of
your head so embodiment practices
whether that be doing some sort of
training
spending time with friends float tanks
meditation martial arts
all that stuff like something that
makes you feel
in your body alive because that'll help
you to get used to switching off
know that if you're asking these sorts
of questions that the outcomes you get
in life are going to be fantastic in any
case because almost no one is asking
these sorts of questions right
you do not need to get answers right now
the goal is to have arrived at an answer
in 30 years
not to have got the answer right this
moment
go for whatever you think is the closest
approximation to a good
direction
and over time just continue to adapt and
move the trajectory that's all you need
to do and you're going to be fine i can
tell
chris strandberg [ __ ] we've been going
for an hour and 20 minutes all right
i'll do a few more uh chris strandberg
now that you've been on rogan do you
feel a deep sense of satisfaction and
accomplishment or has your mind already
started to stress you about achieving
the next thing
yeah
i
would like to say that i sat back and
relaxed and you know patted myself on
the back a lot
but
the drive is difficult to turn off
you know uh
i was very very happy i have been i've
taken time to be grateful and gratitude
has just been like flowing through my
veins
but i'm
constantly thinking about what the next
thing is there's this quote from
sam harris when he's talking about death
in the present moment and he says that
even when we think we're being present
in very subtle ways we're always looking
over the present shoulder we're always
peering past it to see what comes next
and that's something that i try to
deprogram as much as possible
i would certainly say i've been a lot
more present for the success and the
feeling of
um gratitude and
fulfillment that i got from rogan
happening and going well
but very quickly i'm focused on what's
happening next what's the next episode
who do i need to research for like i did
rogan on the monday and then did four
episodes back to back tuesday through
friday that same week so
i don't know i i probably do need to
dial the
water level of work back but then if you
do that you're no longer able to put
your foot on the gas when you need to uh
so it's a it's a difficult one man and
this is why i love having these
conversations and hearing the questions
from you guys because
i'm still going through this stuff i'm
working through this stuff in real time
trying to work out okay how
how tolerant should i be of rest days
without eroding my ability to
continue to obsess and and be fantastic
with stuff how much does the obsession
actually curb my enjoyment of life
because i can't relax and i can relax
but how much relaxation is blah blah
blah
all of these are questions that
everyone's working through and the fact
that i get to talk to you guys about it
and you know
what i'm talking about and you
understand the challenge and kind of
everyone's on the journey together is
just [ __ ] so cool
uh sam g how did you become more
articulate when speaking and how do you
ask better questions when having a
debate slash conversation how to stay
calm during confrontation you're one of
my favorite podcasters thank you sam um
articulate when speaking be precise try
and think about what it is that you're
trying to say the biggest thing is
practice
continue to get thoughts from brain to
mouth as frictionlessly as possible what
is the most precise way to speak it's
not the fewest words it's not the most
words it's not the most fancy words that
you can it's not brevit it's just
what did you mean to say and continue to
refine that this is why sit down with a
friend once a week for half an hour
record the conversation funds are off
and it can be about anything but try and
be as precise as possible work on being
precise as possible
how do you ask better questions when
having a debate such conversation that
is a lot more easy than you might think
so when there is a hole
in what someone puts across you will
feel it it's almost like putting your
hand across the surface of a of a
texture and there's like a little hole
and you go look it's it feels like a
break in the rhythm because you go hang
in a second that's an unsubstantiated
claim or that is um a word that i
haven't heard the definition of before
or whatever so just allow your curiosity
to lead you forward go hang on hang on
what do you mean by that or
how's how's that the case or i'm not
really too sure can you can you can you
elaborate
leaning into that sort of stuff i think
helps you to ask better questions
because
your
subconscious felt sense when it pops up
that's the point at which most of the
people that are listening as well are
going to and if you're in a debate
the audience will be on your side
because if you felt it it's probable
that they felt it as well
how to stay calm during confrontation
that's a difficult one
don't take it too seriously right it's
just a game everyone's gonna die in any
case all of us all of us are gonna die
and in
three months time no one's gonna
remember the conversation that you had
in any case so just enjoy it like
there's no pressure
john shaw i'm 22 years old i have a
great paying job i love and in my free
time i work on my own career i'm mostly
fascinated by things but like philosophy
art history and politics i think my
interests have made it very hard for me
to date i consider myself a good looking
confident guy and i can get a girl when
i want to but when it comes to actually
dating all the women
seem to not have any common interests or
desire to learn anything about my
interests this makes it hard for me to
date especially because i live an hour
away from green bay the closest city my
area is very rural what can i do to
improve my dating life
you have a challenge at the moment john
because at 22 years old most people are
not fascinated by things like philosophy
history art and politics so i would say
just sit tight i know that it sucks and
it's like the classic like older guy
just you know your young bro
advice
however
i genuinely do think that you will be
the perfect partner for someone
when the girls grow up now you could
always date older if you wanted you
could look at girls that are you know in
their late 20s most guys on average
aren't going to want to date older
most people that are around your age are
pretty
kind of shallow
a lot of people i mean i've worked with
these guys and girls the ones that we
selected were the ones that weren't
the ones that had a little bit of
curiosity and intellectual gusto and it
was really [ __ ] hard to find them so
the fact that you have these interests
is amazing just
when it comes to dating perhaps don't
set your intellectual uh
litmus too high like don't have too high
of a set of standards
in terms of what you're expecting for
conversation and
if you do manage to find some super
freak girl at 22 that loves philosophy
and history and politics
fantastic and if not like they'll come
people develop more
mature interests over time your problem
is basically you're like the kid that
hit puberty at nine years old but you
did it intellectually instead so yeah i
think you're just gonna have to hold on
tight man
uh
what else have we got
okay
one
a couple more uh
kevin just a guy called kevin uh top
five interviewer podcaster in existence
today thank you keep up the good work uh
oh that wasn't a question danny danny
cox are you giving yourself the massive
pat on the back you deserve every day
i'm trying i'm getting better man and it
is helped by meaningful messages so for
everyone that's sent cool messages and
said wonderful things over the last few
weeks and forever as well i very much
appreciate you
uh miguel
oxamendi what motivates you more thrill
of victory or the agony of defeat
that's a good question
used to be the agony of defeat i used to
come from a position of not wanting to
lose rather than wanting to win
and
now the more that i keep on winning
the more that winning motivates me
because the fear of failure
is further away
now it would be interesting to see what
would happen if
there is some huge failure because
that's going to be a big challenge right
the fall from grace like this is what
people wait to see
but
i think when i started out the agony of
defeat and not wanting to lose was a big
part whereas now the thrill of victory
and the feeling of a job well done is
what i'm chasing after
there are a lot of questions left i'm
sorry that i didn't get around to them
but
there will be another q a very soon i
appreciate you all thank you i love you
to bits thank you to everyone that
reached out and shared the rogan episode
links for the stuff that i spoke about
in terms of supplements will be below
chriswellx.com
books for the reading list that's it
see you at half a million
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]